buonasera
[Applauso]
accendo subito la macchina così vi
faccio vedere cosa sapeva fare quando lo
abbia lanciato e vi faccio vedere che
può essere utilizzata come una macchina
calcolo qualsiasi quesito dicono i
numeri
si chiede l'operazione la macchina
esegue l'operazione c'è solo da tener
presente che usa la notazione polacca
inversa cioè questa macchina non al
tasto uguale perché è il modo migliore
per poter fare delle operazioni una
dietro l'altra in modo indefinito
ecco questo è l'uso più tranquillo della
macchina però poi aveva anche la
possibilità di eseguire dei programmi è
stata la prima riuscivo a farlo in un
modo estremamente semplice basta leggere
il programma e dico fare il download
della di una applicazione poi si
impostano i numeri di dieci mai numeri
decimali che noi vogliamo e poi diamo i
numeri che servono per questa
applicazione è l'applicazione che ho
caricato è un piano di ammortamento e vi
farà capire come questa macchina ha
cambiato il modo di lavorare di un sacco
di gente questo è un piano ammortamento
quindi un discorso di tipo finanziario
però lo stesso concetto può essere
portato in tutti i settori in cui c'è
bisogno di fare dei calcoli
io per eseguire questo piano di
ammortamento quello che è previsto e che
io introduca un capitale e poi che amo
l'ambientazione poi introduco il numero
degli anni dell'ammortamento e poi
l'interesse con cui chiedo di calcolare
dà il via al programma e la macchina e
comincia a fare il lavoro
ho sbagliato io
comunque è una macchina che mi segue
come lessi da un sacco di tempo e quindi
vediamo se la macchina ragazzi ha deciso
di lasciarmi provo di nuovo e poi s'è
sbagliato
un attimo di pazienza perché il tempo
scorre mi dispiace ha deciso di andare
sa perché non voleva comunque il
concetto che volevo esprimere era il
fatto che prima di questa macchina è uno
doveva continuare lui a fare le
operazioni invece da quando c'è questa
macchina automaticamente lei si arrangia
e sta stampando pensate alcuno che fosse
in banca per clienti ha davanti una
volta diceva se si passa per 15 giorni
devo fare un po di operazioni invece da
quando c'è questa macchina mentre lui
chiacchiere trattiene la macchina di
stampa e colori a con tutte
il tuo piano di ammortamento e così
possiamo mettere le nostre slide e ecco
io voglio raccontarvi la storia di come
siamo arrivati a questa macchina una
storia e la memoria se volete certo
perché fa parte dei miei ricordi ricordi
molto vivi e così la nostra storia
comincia nel 1955 quando adriano
olivetti accetta l'invito della
università di pisa di partecipare a
sviluppare il calcolo tori ceva loro
crea un laboratorio che è il laboratorio
di certe elettroniche con il maglio su
un'altra persona che voglio ricordare e
questo gruppo ea pisa è partito e in
quattro anni facendo tre step cioè una v
0 che a valvole una v nome tav algor
metà transistor è riuscito a lanciare
nel 59 il primo calcolatore elettronico
completamente a transistor della storia
purtroppo e questo è stato un risultato
che se ci pensate un attimo a
incredibile purtroppo poi nel 60 adriano
deve mancare nel 61 moria anche mario
giu
e allora il figlio di adriano roberto
livelli cli vediamo congiu prese un po
in mano quello che era il laboratorio
una delle cose che chi è che fece è
quello di chiedere all'ingegner perotto
di provare utilizzando la tecnologia
delle lea del calcolatore di fare una
macchina da calcolo lawley 20 aveva
fatto la sua fortuna con le macchine
della calcolo meccaniche e aveva poi
tirato fuori il calcolatore dice ma con
quella tecnologia dovrebbe fare una
macchia da cancro ed è questo che ha
scatenato quello che è stato il lavoro
una ricerca che abbiamo è che poi ci ha
portato a fare questa macchina a
lanciare il primo attacco primo personal
computer centra un po la memoria perché
una delle prime cose che fece per 8 è
quello di considerare visto che lui
voleva puntare a una macchina che avesse
suo spazio da un punto di vista
commerciale non soltanto uno studio
decise di rinunciare in prima battuta
però che era la memoria delle leal 9300
e la memoria delle lea era una memoria
nuclei quello che vedete un modulo
costituito da sette piani ogni piano a
10 mila nuclei filati ciascuno di lupo
infilato con quattro fili tutto filato
amara quindi potete immaginare quello
che era il costo la complessità di
queste memorie dice se noi partiamo da
questa memoria non riusciremo
sicuramente a realizzare qualcosa che
sta sulla scrivania che costi poco e che
quindi possa essere accettabile come una
macchina da calcola evoluta ci ha fatto
allora provare come primo esercizio
quello di utilizzare una vecchia memoria
la linea magneto stivali sulla destra
vedete quella che poi è andato in
produzione sulla sinistra il primo
prototipo che ci è stato costruito per
fare il nostro esperimento questo il
principio devo andare a veloce perché
sennò non arrivò
abbiamo deciso di fare una macchina
programmabile avete visto che la
macchina ha eseguito un programma bontà
sua questa volta comunque
abbiamo definito un linguaggio di 15
istruzioni ci siamo convinti che fosse
semplice e facile da usare e quindi
abbiamo realizzato un prototipo che
esegue una macchina che eseguiva questo
linguaggio l'abbiamo testata e abbiamo
capito che c'era un problemino di fondo
quando aspettavamo la macchina si
perdeva il programma tutte le volte che
dovevamo introdurlo bisogna fare a mano
i programmi di una certa lunghezza fino
al 120 istruzioni facendoli a marito
dicendo amanda si potevano fare degli
errori quindi dovevamo controllare poi
il programma che avevamo introdotto e
ritrovarlo e allora tutto il vantaggio
della programmabilità andava un po per
tutto e allora abbiamo deciso di cercare
un modo perché il programma nota
definito una volta scritto è in macchina
potesse essere memorizzato e poi
utilizzato senza doverlo riprodurre
un'altra volta e abbiamo definito la
cartolina magnetica stata l'invenzione
del primo supporto magnetico discreto
della storia
e così a completa ha completato la
funzionalità della macchina
la macchina ha assunto uno schema
architetturale molto semplice che qui
vedete una rete logica allora non
c'erano le cpu una memoria un organo di
input della tastiera o nord di auto
perché la stampantina è l'organo di
memoria di secondo livello che è la
cartolina magnetica per le applicazioni
legge è però ecco da ricordare in quel
tempo che lo diventi aver dovuto cedere
la divisione elettronica la general
elettric tutto è stato quindi venduto
ceduto diciamo tra noi gruppetto
dell'igea carotto in genere per 8 a a un
certo punto dice in questa situazione un
po caotica e meglio che facciamo qualche
fotografia io le riporto devo andare
veloce ecco e queste sono le fotografie
di quello che stavamo facendo a metà del
appena abbiamo finito di diciamo
collaudare questo secondo livello di
prototipo definitivo il proto la chiuso
in una scatola e l'ha presentato
al management e olivetti quello tra
l'altro quindi una chiamata la pelle
difesa perottina in onore liberotto
l'affrettato in prima persona natale
capellaro che era stato il padre del
calcolo meccaniche dolori vecchi
abbiamo tentato io c'ero perché facevo
proprio dimostratore e quello è stato un
momento topico cioè il gene x 8 ha
spiegato a cappellaro come funziona la
linea maniera oggettiva cosa faceva la
macchina eccetera poi si è messo ad
aspettare il verdetto di cappellaro
cappellaro 30 secondi almeno è rimasto
in silenzio tutti noi ad aspettare lui
che era il padre della del calcolo
meccanico diciamo delle olivetti e non
solo in quel momento tra l'altro lo
rivela tesa a ritornare i suoi fasti
attraverso nuove generazioni di macchine
meccaniche natale capellaro dopo una
trentina di secondi è appreso ha messo
la mano sulla spalla dell'ingegnere
perotto e ha detto caro ingegnere
vedendo questa macchina io capisco che
l'era del calcolo meccanico è finita e
per noi è stato un momento molto
particolare tra l'altro per me sentito
da quest'uomo
ho letto questo veramente era un uomo
grande era così veramente fra l'altro è
un operaio che è diventato ingegnere
honoris causa all'università di bari
quindi la macchina poi è stata vestita
da mario bellini l'architetto management
olivetti anche se non credeva a questo
tipo di macchine ha deciso di
presentarlo negli stati uniti io sono
andato come vedete c'era all'expo
mondiale e ad avviare il discorso per la
presentazione e ed è stato presentato
fatto una convention e poi è andato al
bim di new york
questa macchina è stato presentato un po
alla chetichella però la gente quando ha
capito di cosa si trattava in
particolare giornalisti hanno scritto è
nato un nuovo strumento e
il primo desktop computer della storia e
qualcuno ha scritto addirittura pensiamo
che avremo un computer su ogni scrivania
prima di avere la seconda auto nel
garage ed è stato proprio così se
pensate uno dei primi clienti è stata la
nasa che stava preparando lo sbarco alla
luna ne ha comprate piu di 40 guarda
caso nella presentazione del programma
che fino agli stati uniti è stato fatto
tracciare quello che è stato all'orbita
di un satelliti in quel momento gli
americani stavano soffrendo perché
volevano da sulla luna ma i primi andare
nello spazio erano stati i russi come
dicono ea comperate li abbiamo due
fotografie delle scrivanie della nasa in
cui ci sono due programma 101 ne abbiamo
anche una grazia comunque circa 45
questo praticamente con questa
presentazione l'olivetti anche il
management olivetti che non credeva in
questa macchina è stato costretto a
mandarla in produzione ha cominciato le
produzioni l'inizio del 77 e da lì è
andato avanti perché non molti sanno ma
di fatto da lì è cominciato una nuova
storia perché l'olivetti ha ricostruito
su questa macchina a quello che è stata
il suo mondo la sua elettronica da sua
informatica la sua capacità di fare
sistemi da lina lancio quando è morto
all'olivetti non era perché non avesse
funzionato discorso di personal computer
adesso per finire io racconto un
aneddoto che nel 2012 c'è stato al
politecnico di torino una gara voluta da
bollione che è un appassionato di
everyone e la gara è stato una buona
gara colpi di bit si è chiamata fra
programma 101 apple one e amstrad apple
one era del 76 questa del 65 e la mostra
dell 84
ha vinto la programma 101 uno dei
programmi uno dei programmi che noi
abbiamo portato perché abbia portato un
po di programmi di lavori per
confrontare eccetera con le cose uno dei
programmi è stato se possiamo passare
all
la cosa è stato la ricerca dei numeri
primi vediamo se questa volta mi
impedisce la macchina
la macchina non può dirmi perché ho
messo 0 scusate sono io che sbaglio
avevo e son certo noi il diwali ecco la
macchina sta se possiamo mettere di
nuovo la sta cercando i numeri primi un
programmino che andrà andrebbe avanti
penso che o meno all'infinito che non si
vede ma si sente sta trovando ogni tanto
i numeri primi è un programma a cui una
volta ha dato l'avvio praticamente va
avanti finché non vai su prodi capacità
quindi andare avanti fare qualche decina
d'anni prima di fermarsi ma io lo
fermerà prima perché sennò si stanca
detto che non è venuto fuori
il big bang dice stop e quindi io sono
questo e trasmettere e affermarmi qui
fermo anche la macchina e vi saluto
[Applauso]